does this sound good uh I cannot hear my
own voice
can you hear me
you are here
can you hear it now testing yeah no I
can yeah okay can you guys talk together
hello hello hello
um he's a little loud do you want to put
those headphones on
yeah
so we're here we did a little
documentary you're doing the documentary
yeah we're about to go live we're doing
a podcast and a documentary
we are live oh we're live right now yeah
cool
volume it's still I'm gonna make it
louder yeah
is that better
are these noise canceling that it's
raining on or
um oh well do you guys feel like you're
okay because I've matched your game now
I think it I think it sounds fine mine's
a little my my headphones might be a
little bit loud
the games in the same world so you
should be okay but Gary you're loud as
[ __ ] yeah I'm I'm really loud I'll just
keep I'll just keep a uh I'll keep my
voice
recording okay cool
all right guys I want to get out of your
hair and record this I'm going to charge
some batteries we're live now so you're
gonna have a handheld BTS camera yes yes
cool
all right
so we're doing it
we're here and we're queer yeah we have
no fear
we're drinking beer
white clothes did you do you have one no
no yeah can you give me a white
claw
thanks man so how do you think that
interview went downstairs it was fun
I was just talking you know I'm always
talking I don't I don't like talking
which is weird but yeah I mean to me I
was just talking so hopefully it was fun
I tried to make it listenable and
watchable it was intellectual and you're
very well spoken
you're the second uh Spotlight interview
that we've done so far for this
documentary that we're working on that's
fun it was the first uh Uncle laser oh
right yeah so we we want to have a
contrast so we're interviewing you
because you've been doing it a long time
and you're very successful and then we
want to have that contrast with somebody
like Uncle laser who's who's pretty much
brand new
yeah uh who's pretty much thanks brother
who's pretty much brand new and
um is you know getting relative success
very quickly but we'll see uh where he
goes I think he's gonna be successful he
just needs to write some like get joke
writing down because you're really good
at writing jokes you do it every week
for kill Tony and you've said you write
what 12 2 000 words a day try to write 2
000 words every day it's like a diary
entry you know it doesn't have to be
good
uh and you know sometimes I'm like [ __ ]
I don't want to write this down this
isn't a good thought and so I don't
write anything down
and then eventually I'm just sitting
there just staring at the phone so like
I sometimes I'm like just write it
doesn't matter whatever No One's Gonna
read it
except the government
yeah the government FBI agent is reading
that
yeah the FBI is reading it and that's
bad because they might think I'm like a
crazy person you know what kind of what
kind of bad thoughts do you have or do
you not even want to mention about
bad thoughts
um I want to redistribute wealth oh [ __ ]
you're communist yeah
foreign
Jesus Christ I mean so do you right
um I want to redistribute wealth to
myself exactly yeah but I don't really
care about other people's money because
it's not my business well if they take
it all then
I don't I don't like paying taxes
because I feel like that's
redistributing it to the government
which then they just usually steal
right but don't we control the
government through votes no
well ideally ideally yes no idea
shouldn't we fix the government instead
of just being like [ __ ] the government I
think the way that you fix the
government is by down scaling it I'm not
necessarily opposed to taxes but I don't
but then corporations will rule the
world I don't trust them either that's a
good point it's a balancing act for sure
we're also sort of shifting into like
the future into a different Paradigm you
know it's a weird it's a weird we live
in a weird time for sure
uh cultural and technological shifts we
have to figure something out
we're gonna do something different yeah
we can't keep doing what we're doing I
think that we need to
um
probably legalize prostitution
okay I think that's the most important
thing we can do right now uh to stop
school shootings
and also I think we really should
consider federally legalizing marijuana
definitely yeah those are the two big
ones for me we are I think we're
considering it I mean we so everyone is
just going to have their dick sucked and
they're going to be smoking which you
don't even do you know I don't even
smoke pot yeah I'd take uh
amphetamine salts and drink a lot of
beer and um other than that I don't
really do anything else I just do that
and I make phone calls and
um
set up Productions production meetings
occasionally I get behind a camera and
film
but uh yeah you know that's that's what
I uh that's what I do that's fun you
know like you are uh you're in your
world and you gotta do the best in your
world and not think about too much about
like other people's worlds because then
you're not going to do as good as in
your world right yeah well I like to
focus on myself man I like to stay out
of other people's business because that
just causes problems for for me and I
think it's generally the same for
everybody you know if you're trying to
think about somebody else's problems and
[ __ ] then you're just getting that
you're putting those obstacles in the
way of your own success and what Lane
that you're in you know what I mean but
isn't like a lot of success
collaborative people yeah together and
it's not like just worrying about their
problems but just like you know uh
in a business sense right is that what
we're talking about
maybe well that's what I'm saying like
like in a personal capacity whatever
anybody else's personal [ __ ] is I
just don't care
you know and I kind of feel like embody
their problems and like try to be like
oh what would I do when it comes to your
turn then you'll have all this wealth of
experience yeah I guess that's true but
I also
I kind of feel like whenever I try to
help somebody else with their [ __ ] it it
is like drains my own energy to deal
with my own problems but also sometimes
I think trying to help somebody ends up
uh enabling them to make bad decisions
over and over and almost handicaps them
in a way because then you're helping
somebody solve their problems instead of
help instead of letting them experience
the the pain and suffering that they
need to go through in order to better
um deal with like learn and gain wisdom
from it and then deal with their own
[ __ ] I mean yeah you got to go through
your own life
but I mean yeah it's good to work
together sometimes too dude so you were
talking about uh on this so so we're
doing a documentary it's being
um executively produced and financed by
Adam hartle and the Sunset Strip comedy
club and we are getting the whole Austin
comedy scene sort of uh on a macro level
we're talking about like how it was
before and what it's changed into and
the PC stuff and Hench cliff and the
pong dang thing and Rogan moving here
and all that stuff and then on a micro
level we're getting people's stories
like you laser Leonardo Joni Mitch
burrow David Lucas uh you know there's a
handful of other people in there who
were we've got that are uh sort of that
we haven't interviewed yet but we have
slated to and uh so we're working on
that and we we spotlighted you obviously
and in your interview earlier we
we were talking to you about a lot of
stuff and I think what resonated with me
the most that you were talking about was
suffering and how you said I didn't mind
it yeah I totally agree with that I
think that if you don't like like if you
suffer for nine years like you said and
then somebody starts suffering at that
time when you're already nine years
ahead of them they there's there's
literally no nothing you can exchange
for that nine years of suffering right
you have a head start you got an
advantage you just compounded your
advantage so that's good yeah it's like
but like yeah you don't want to just
suffer for no reason it's like it's got
to be purposeful and it's got to be
contributing to the actual thing because
if it's uh aimless then you're just like
damaging yourself yeah you know and then
that and then people that do stuff like
that that's a self-sabotage
you know yeah if you're just like
aimlessly
like torturing yourself for no [ __ ]
reason then
you're actually doing the inverse of
what you're trying it's counterintuitive
you're trying to get yourself further
but if you're doing it aimlessly then
you're just damaging your capability of
being successful in the future but if
you're suffering with a goal and a
purpose then it's basically fortifying
yourself and you're galvanizing your
your skill set to be able to make more
of a
impact in whatever industry you're in
yeah I mean suffering shouldn't be the
goal it should be the byproduct of
whatever you're doing that you have to
sacrifice in other areas
um but yeah just like the practice and
the actual doing it is I think better
because like so many times people have
meetings about things and they like talk
and think about it and they know don't
actually do it like I think doing things
is way better dude the amount of [ __ ]
people in comedy specifically that talk
about doing something and never do [ __ ]
is it's almost unfathomable yeah it's
crazy yeah I mean it's not that hard to
be successful and that's maybe that's
maybe I'm being a little bit dramatic
but
uh you got to put in the hours and the
work and the suffering but if you try to
do something and then you just follow
through you can be relatively successful
regardless of your Raw Talent OR skill
set yeah and if you're not doing it then
then what are you doing yeah you know
what I mean uh yeah I mean yeah I think
it's better to do it
uh yeah because then that's a good thing
about comedy it's like there's so many
open mics and people just get addicted
to doing it over and over again which
can be bad because then you might not be
thinking about it and you're just going
up there doing the same thing
yeah how what's what's the feedback like
um
add an open mic like is that is that
helpful because a lot of times the open
mic sometimes they're just like other
shitty comics in the crowd you know what
I mean yeah I mean it's the truth no
matter what it is like
even if like they don't laugh and you
make them like whoa whoa or like huh
like maybe that's good enough but yeah
it's hard because you're trying to get
such a big reaction and to not get
anything as hard but yeah you can tell
what the audience is thinking and you
should be like trying to figure out what
they're thinking instead of just being
you can feel the energy noise no noise
yeah it should be like yeah getting past
the noise
to what they're actually thinking or
feeling and then you can talk to them
better and trick them better get them to
dude your your life probably feels
pretty surreal right now huh you just
did Rogan yesterday yeah that's [ __ ]
insane yeah
yeah I mean dude when I met you you're
living in that van
when did we meet
right around the time you moved here I
thought yeah we were hanging out we hung
out at the nether hour house yeah but
yeah yeah dude you took a picture of uh
of Me and Bobby that's pretty iconic in
my mind yeah of us shirtless just wasted
with cowboy hats on yeah that's sort of
the energy back then oh yeah it was a
lot more it was a lot more partying and
crazy and chaotic and now everybody's
kind of putting their nose to the
grindstone because we're all yeah it's
like but back then it was like we were
way ahead of the game because no one was
doing anything so even if I did like one
podcast
it was better than most people I know
dude that's so crazy man yeah that's uh
those are like the Glory Days almost you
know yeah in a weird way yeah we had
nothing no responsibilities dude
dude I uh that's that's [ __ ] insane
Okay so
I was telling you this earlier but I
just want to reiterate this so I went to
a wedding in Sacramento a couple weeks
ago and when I was there I was talking
to uh
um some people like some of my boys that
I hadn't seen in a couple years and they
were like hey man so you started this
this Media company out in Austin you're
working with a lot of these cool people
and you're doing all this cool [ __ ] and
and like everybody was like yeah we're
so proud of you and blah blah you're
like a you're like a success story and I
was like well
yeah I'm like doing something I've enjoy
doing and getting paid for it so yeah in
that capacity it's successful not where
I want to be at yet but I'm getting
there and this one guy goes
he goes yeah yeah that's cool but dude
the coolest thing I've seen is that Hans
Kim roasted you on kill Tony and said
you were bipolar at a Christmas parties
or whatever it was and it was one of
those moments where I just thought like
this guy like the the most like
admirable you know uh successful person
that he saw me interact with that he
enjoyed the most was you telling me that
I was bipolar like I just thought that
was [ __ ] hilarious because when I see
you I think of us like partying and
hanging out and [ __ ] and when he sees
that he sees like a famous comic it's
just [ __ ] crazy dude right and we're
like at the level where we can just hang
out and have a good time yeah and we're
calling each other bipolar and stuff
yeah well it's crazy well you might be
right
I could be there's definitely something
going on yeah well I was diagnosed
bipolar yeah but I don't think it was an
accurate diagnosis
so I mean I don't think like we should
try to go for normal I think it should
just be whoever you are
I agree with that especially with uh
comedy man
um I think that
um
when you're the most yourself is when
you're at your funniest that's my take
on it although I guess there's a lot of
people who kind of put on a face when
they're on stage and they're really
funny too but I like the people that I
think are the most genuine but what is
yourself maybe you're yourself when you
don't know who you are and you're just
being relaxed and just being able to be
multiple people like maybe being
yourself is like schizophrenic not the
best way to think about it for some
people because like like yeah I don't I
don't like to think about who I am or
like what what would I do with my
personality that I've established I'd
rather just like feel what I'm feeling
and then respond and it's like I don't
want to have to like think about who I
am I'd rather just well I think that is
when you who you are who you are I know
it's a vague definition it's very
convoluted but I I think I understand
what you're saying
so uh yeah I mean it's like a different
way to live life are you like uh
going crazy you uh wake up pretty late
and film podcasts do they film early
ever dude no they never do but my uh I
think I think like
I think people get the wrong idea of uh
like who I am like I kind of act like I
exaggerate my personality you know what
I mean people think I'm just crazy yeah
it's more fun well yeah like half the
time dude I'm like at a computer editing
you know what I mean so you're uh you're
mostly sedentary and you're like yeah
you're like a nerd no mostly okay I
shouldn't say half the time maybe like a
quarter of the time usually I'm like
pacing around on the phone making phone
calls and just setting things up and
coordinating Productions
um and then like another like a quarter
of the time I'm actually physically
recording podcasts in the studio and
then another quarter of the time I'm
probably
um like sitting down editing specials
and stuff like that because like right
now I'm editing JPC or special nice and
that's a lot of work because it's it's a
big [ __ ] production large video file
size you got to make like proxies and
all that like you know editing kind of
lingo [ __ ] but
um it to sit down and really like make
sure cuts are perfectly timed and a
comedy special is very meticulous and
it's very time consuming you have to
choose artistically when to cut like
after he says this sentence then you cut
to that yeah and I'm I'm doing it with
uh Brent Pella do you know him no he's
um he lives out in L.A he's a common
he's on MTV that Nick Cannon Nick
Cannon's presents Wilder now well now
yeah okay he's like probably the only
white dude on there but
um he's the one who directed it so I'm
working with him and we you know
simultaneously are choosing which uh
edits we like and which to keep and
which camera shots and then we take
crowd shots from the second show because
you know you record two shows it's just
it's a whole it's a whole process to
make a really good comedy special and I
hope I'm
I'm pretty confident it's going to come
out really well but sometimes you know
you get a little bit nervous when you
work on bigger jobs like that you know
what I mean yeah it's a lot of power
were you were you nervous on Rogan yeah
yeah how how much it's like oh [ __ ]
people are watching this but then it's
not really because it's pre-recorded and
then it's like they pre-record them
you're right they do now huh yeah
otherwise I'd be there right now
um but yeah
um well they used to do them live they
used to uh but then it's like how long
can you be that nervous for how long can
you think about that for it's not
entertaining it's not a rich thing to
think about to be like people are
watching people are watching people are
watching like you can only do that for
so long so then I get exhausted of that
and then I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm in a room
with Joe Rogan
and that kind of takes over precedence
over oh [ __ ] you know people are
watching like yeah it's not rich enough
to sink my teeth into just be like
nervous so yeah it's pretty easy to get
over it relatively quickly yeah yeah I
feel like that's how most entertainers
are
people that are used to be I'm just more
interested in the actual thing like yeah
being nervous about it I haven't had a
chance to watch it yet I just saw your
post I knew that you and Tony were yeah
it's pretty much
um
it's a pretty big thing so I'm glad that
uh you were from what I the clip I saw
earlier when we were downstairs you were
you were cheesing the whole time dude
yeah smile all smiles yeah I was having
a blast yeah well because you usually
have a pretty deadpan look on your face
like
you know you're just like your Hans
that's who you are so see and you're
like smiling your ass off it's kind of
funny you know yeah
yeah I mean it's usually like
uh around Joe is when I'll do that
but uh did I get it no
uh yeah those uh it was a fun time it
was great uh but it's like I've hung out
with Joe so much
that I got a lot of the other stuff out
oh yeah you hang out with him a lot yeah
I don't even I don't even know I figured
you just did a bunch of shows with them
does he hang out yeah we hang out all
the time
That's crazy dude that's so bizarre to
me because I I grew up uh
pretty much watching his podcast for
[ __ ] ever dude it's bizarre there was
a lot of times in my life where he would
do those pods with David Goggins yeah
the dude I'm getting bit by that goddamn
mosquito uh he would do pods with David
Goggins when I was in college uh so the
first week I was at UT I was 24 maybe
and um I had a I gave my my I had a kid
my
at the time my girlfriend she gave birth
to my son the first week I was at UT and
like within a month or so she was like
you can't see your kid and it became all
[ __ ] up it's a whole story but um
there were times when I was super
[ __ ] depressed you know like by
myself I got no family in Texas I'm out
here completely alone I can't talk to my
son I'm going to school all the people
in the [ __ ] at UT were like super
super liberal because I went to the J
school for journalism I was originally a
journalist and uh they were super
liberal I didn't have any like real
[ __ ] friends you know yeah they were
18. I was no I was 24. you were going to
School freshman year at 24. this is this
was my junior year because I went to
school in Santa Barbara
uh California yeah you got my associates
in English first so at least you're kind
of older which made it worse because I
was already over all the [ __ ]
I was already over all the [ __ ] I
was like dude I've [ __ ] done all this
already I've already partied I've
already done cocaine I've already done
Molly I've got a kid a hundred girls of
that kind of [ __ ] I didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah so I was like I felt super [ __ ]
isolated and alone I felt really alone
but I felt isolated by my peers because
they didn't agree with me politically so
like anytime I spoke up in class people
were like oh here's Gary going off on
his [ __ ] again you know what I mean
yeah and I was [ __ ] over it anyways I
would watch these podcasts like I would
get like super depressed dude like
almost like borderline suicidal
sometimes like I would think about
killing myself and I would watch the
David Goggins
uh Clips where he's like you know
basically like
do it like you're you're tough enough to
like get through this [ __ ] and if you're
not then you're a [ __ ] and I would
watch that [ __ ] I'm pretty sure it like
stopped me from killing myself then
again maybe it was just my own my own
mind telling me to keep moving forward
no that's good you felt positive
emotions you know like I feel like
podcasts were my friend especially jokes
yeah dude for real like I would be like
I need a friend let me just turn on my
friends right now yeah then I could just
talk to him 100 that's a really good way
to put it actually yeah it's like
friends on demand
yeah it kind of is yeah yeah which is
not healthy I guess no not at all but
it's the same way with kill Tony but
it's better than nothing it's the same
thing when I whenever we go to kill Tony
on Mondays it's like a [ __ ] ritual
man I go down there and I'm like every
time I'm just like oh cool I'm in a
place where people
generally like me and I can enjoy this
without really having to be like
concerned about any sort of you know
like like I'm not gonna have any like
negative impact on this you know I'm
part of this like The Kill Tony family's
going Tony chugging along yeah and it's
all it's also just genuinely [ __ ]
hilarious yeah so it's nice to be able
to just sit down and laugh because I'm
so [ __ ] busy all the time kill Tony's
probably the only thing I
go to every single week I used to go to
Secret show every week because I would
film those and
um that was cool too but I just don't do
that anymore I don't have the time to do
it I I guess like do you still go to
Cutthroat karaoke all the time I go
every now and then yeah it's tough I uh
I like to do karaoke I can't do it and
not sign up and then I sign up and I
pick some I like to take risks yeah and
yeah what song did you do last time very
well last time I did remember the name
by Fort Minor
20 power 20 will and a hundred percent
Reason To Remember the Name
yeah dude that that's that song's
[ __ ] hilarious I I I that's a good
choice that's a good choice it's so
those guys took themselves way too
seriously yeah
it's like so easy to make fun of it's
because it's [ __ ] insane dude who
makes a song like that that's crazy but
that's good to have some people like
that it's good to have that sort of
engine yeah like that earnestness that's
why I like a lot of those metal and punk
people are so like self-destructive is
because they're like
it's either complete earnestness
earnesty and authenticity or it's just
like yeah yeah well I look so stupid
it's like they have no chill yeah
they're [ __ ] well that's because
they're all [ __ ] nut cases dude they
should all be locked inside of an asylum
well I think it's good to have
neurodiversity
oh okay I guess I'm wrong
thanks for bringing me on here and tell
me I'm wrong Hans well why are you
suggesting that we lock people up in
asylums
uh well you know you're a comedian I
thought you would recognize that I was
[ __ ] joking but I guess not so am I
oh I'm joking about not understanding
you [ __ ] accepted me dude
um I think it's great to
um joke about like what you're afraid of
like are you afraid of getting locked up
uh yeah actually that's probably the
only thing in life I live I'm
legitimately
have a fear of is going to prison
so is that like a metaphor for like
Society is gonna
trap you and tap you down I don't know
man I don't know about all that [ __ ] but
I just I don't want to go to jail I've
been to jail a lot especially when I was
younger and it [ __ ] is horrible jail
is hell dude yeah I mean it's not a have
you been to jail have you been arrested
I've been arrested yes
I get it I don't think so
um what do you go to jail for
shoplifting what Target are you kidding
me dude I just got caught shoplifting in
Mexico
and then I drove an ATV into a tree
drunk
in Mexico yeah it was fun I had a good
time dude that mosquito has bit me twice
now
are you sure it's the same one
you think there's two you could be right
um yeah so we were at we're on this
excursion
and
um I I needed bug spray and um I mean I
had cash in my pocket I could afford it
I just you know I just grabbed the bug
spray and I sprayed it all over me
and um in the store and then I was about
to just walk out with it and the Mexican
security guy was like hey you got to pay
for that and I was like
whatever dude and I bought it
I didn't get like I wasn't about to get
in trouble but that's what happened and
then and then uh we had a bunch of uh oh
yeah yeah yeah bring that in here
this is how well does this thing work
that's pretty good is it loaded up how
can I tell if it's loaded you gotta [ __ ]
it
oh man
this is probably a probably a bad idea
let's just leave it right here either
one of us can okay use that to
just don't shoot me in the face with
that please yeah
um but yeah then we did this uh ATV
thing we went into a Cenote and swam
around and [ __ ] like that but uh like in
a cave in a Cenote and then we got on
these ATVs and I had like flip-flops on
and like I had these like short shorts
on I looked like a like a dad from the
from the 70s and I'm right on this ATV
and the guide that guides you through
the jungle so there's like six of us on
ATVs driving through the jungle and then
there's a guy at the front and he the
first turn when you go around he just
rips it and he's flying like just like
he's like almost jumping over some of
these bumps and I'm like [ __ ] okay
let's go and so I was keeping up with
him as quickly as I could and we and
right before this they ask you if you
want to purchase insurance on the
vehicle and I was like no I'm not gonna
crash this thing first turn we go around
I slid straight into a [ __ ] tree and
I like got out of it real quick and then
turned the other corner and he's like
could you keep up and I looked at him
and I thought he like saw me hit this
tree and I was like [ __ ] dude they're
gonna charge me like 600 bucks for this
and uh but he but he didn't even know
that I hit the [ __ ] tree so I was
like yeah I could keep up but I almost
[ __ ] destroyed this ATV
um but I didn't and then
I bought cocaine from the cartel
and it wasn't really that great it was a
cool trip it could be better yeah dude
seriously I really did but
dude it was funny man like I followed
this guy into a [ __ ] I really
probably shouldn't be telling the story
but I already started and it's live
uh which I followed this guy into like a
like a little like Market offshoot off
the main street in uh Playa and he leads
me to this like jewelry store that he
says he owns and and operates with his
like family or whatever and there's
three guys outside and they're all
speaking Spanish and they're like
looking at me all weird and I I speak
enough Spanish to understand what they
were saying and they were kind of like
look at this guy kind of deal like look
at this wetto you know what I mean and
the dude that was buying the [ __ ] from
was looking at me all like like like
like I was like this like
like what's the term
like like it's Golden Goose you know
he's like oh this is a guy I'm gonna
like make this money off of tonight so
he brings over uh he brings over this
other dude he brings up the Coke and I'm
like yo like I want to test this [ __ ]
first then I test it and then I
bargained down a better price and all
that [ __ ] but while it was all
happening he just looks at me and he
goes he's like I know you're nervous
weto don't be nervous and I was like I'm
not [ __ ] nervous dude like don't
[ __ ] put that on me man it was weird
I don't know why I all of a sudden had
like balls to get to like check nuts
with a dude that was in the cartel but I
think I think it was just like he was
just trying to say that to me so I
wouldn't try to barter the price with
them you know what I mean right he's
trying to make you nervous Yeah by
saying that yeah yeah yeah I mean it's
all about fear it's like oh you're
fearful I'm not fearful are you no wait
I'm fearful now wait why am I fearful
it's like I don't know it's like not a
rich enough Dynamic where it's like
Alpha Beta I feel like real life there's
more going on yeah if you're just
thinking about it like that then it's
probably not Alpha Beta Sigma
do you ever yeah do you follow that page
no the sigma grind set Instagram page no
I don't know it's [ __ ] insane it's
crazy it's hilarious it's just a joke
page but it's pretty funny yeah it's
funny
uh it's like
a cougar killing a three-legged dog
Sigma grind set
don't go after the one with four legs
yeah what is Sigma what does that even
mean I actually don't understand
another option from Alpha and beta it's
just like it's not either I'm just apart
from it but really you're just like a
loser
dude I have a friend that calls himself
a sigma male and I pretty much said the
same thing to him I was like yeah I
think you're just a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] dude yeah you're not an alpha or a
beta you're just a piece of [ __ ] yeah
um yeah but it's an alternative to a
very restrictive
perspective the the black and white
binary yeah
yeah
so uh what do you what is like
what is like uh something that uh you
had trouble with in college because you
were not liberal everyone else was
liberal you're not liberal that's like
something that so in uh I'm not even I
wouldn't even necessarily necessarily
say I'm not even uh not liberal but I'm
not like
neoliberal like modern day like you know
social justice [ __ ] um but uh just
having like generally like making
friends
was difficult in college I have no
friends from UT almost none maybe
because they were all like well because
they thought I was a bad person that was
really harsh yeah I thought I was a bad
person because I [ __ ]
like thought about things differently
than they did it's a very restrictive
mindset to have yeah they're judging you
they're open-minded and then they say
that they are yeah I'm open-minded I'm
liberal I accept everybody closed-minded
to you because you're not open-minded
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy meanwhile I
would consider myself very open-minded
um but maybe I'm not I don't [ __ ]
know man
so what do you think about
the queen dying [ __ ] the queen I was
talking to Brian about that earlier yeah
why are we worshiping random powerful
people it's insane it's crazy it's like
damn [ __ ] all of them plus half of them
[ __ ] kids yeah that's how we get bad
things if you start worshiping the queen
then you're like giving up power
yeah it's nuts the fact that they're
even in existence still is a [ __ ]
travesty dude
yeah
that's how we used to live for a long
time it's like how you it's like an old
way of being it's like a feudal system
yeah let one person rule over everybody
and then everyone else is like trying to
make them the best and then they get to
do whatever they want it's not a very
you know like in war they have uh like
little units and like a sergeant and
everyone like if you're in a war and
there's a general that's like okay you
guys go here and you guys go there and
I'll be here like then you don't adapt
to situations quick enough but if
everyone is independent and everyone's
like okay we gotta go take this house
down because the sniper is shooting us
you don't have to wait for like a
Central Command it's not an efficient
way
to you think like so you're thinking
like guerrilla warfare is more effective
basically I think individual control
like yeah yeah yeah if everyone is
thinking for themselves then you have 10
million brains thinking as opposed to
one brain but that's also played out to
play Devil's Advocate you've got a lot a
lot lot more room for argument and
difference of opinion when that comes to
play right but just because everyone's
thinking for themselves doesn't mean it
has to be arguments we're very good at
working together that's like our whole
development that's why our brains are so
big is to be able to accommodate other
people's thoughts and stuff
yeah but why then why do people still
have such a [ __ ] problem
understanding other people's opinions
and having issues with empathy and stuff
like that you know well I think it's
economic I think a lot of people are
struggling they're poor and if there's
not enough money in the system it's not
ideal yeah but dude some of the most
empathetic people I've ever met and
maybe this is uh supporting your point
or maybe not I don't know but some of
the most empathetic people I've ever met
have been people that have [ __ ] grew
up without a lot yeah I mean you have to
because that's the only thing you have
but so you would think comes to like
food like you're struggling to survive
like you're not gonna like I mean yeah
like if there was if there was one one
hot if I was in a room
with you
and there's one hot dog on the table
and that's all we have to eat for a
month
I would have to kill you to eat that hot
dog you know what I mean right it's a
famine mentality and if you take away
resources from a large group of people
they're going to be fighting over the
scraps but if there's three hot dogs in
this room yeah I would still probably
eat all those hot dogs in 30 days
maybe I'm just selfish I don't know well
no maybe I wouldn't though well we're
friends so I probably wouldn't I'll
probably share with you but if somebody
I didn't know well I think the great
thing about people is self-sacrifice
that's something that we treasure you
know Jesus Superman Batman you know yeah
yeah yeah Batman and Jesus Superman
but yeah it's like a thing that we
treasure it's something that we try to
Foster in each other dude you you really
see the world through a really nice
light I wish I was like you I really I'm
serious I'm dead is that nice because
I'm so morose and low energy so much of
the time and you're happy and high
energy yeah we're pretty opposite
actually in terms of personality I would
say but I do well I will
have people like that like I know my
best friends are super mellow people
because I'm so out of my mind I don't
think you have to be exactly the same to
get along with people I think sometimes
that's even worse yeah no I agree that's
why all my relationships have been
failed because every girlfriend I've
ever had is five foot three tan and uh
exactly like me
yeah loud and yeah loud and a stripper
or whatever you know
a loud stripper
the better if you like this
oh thank you
um
yeah I I actually tend to not get along
with people that are similar to me yeah
it's more work I don't know why I think
it's maybe it's because I hate myself I
think like in our narcissistic primitive
State we're like everyone should be like
me but then I've never thought that
though why do you date people that are
exactly like you then
I think it stems from a place of
understanding because I understand them
better and it's easier for me to
understand something that's similar to
me than it is to understand the woman
that's different than me because I
already struggle understanding the
female mind yeah because it's very like
feelings and emotion oriented and mood
oriented as opposed to like somebody
like me who's like go go go go high
octane let's get this done I don't give
a [ __ ] about the consequences at the
time let's just do this thing and get it
done and we'll figure it out later you
know what I mean yeah it's good to have
that that's why men and women work so
well together sometimes because like
women are the yin to the game yeah they
slow you down or like or maybe maybe I
just like need somebody like you in my
life you know have you ever thought
about maybe boy maybe being gay you want
to be gay with me
I could be your girlfriend
um no I I know what you mean you're
you're right I just need to
I'm a good communicator but I don't I'm
not get it under sometimes I struggle
with like empathy I can sympathize with
people but I struggle with empathy with
with women because like I didn't grow up
with an emotional mother you know my
mom's like pretty robotic and my dad's
like a [ __ ] cartoon character you've
met him right probably my dad yeah
covered in tattoos yeah that's he he's
like a cartoon character the guy's
[ __ ] crazy and my mom's like and he's
so he's like an emotional [ __ ] crazy
guy and then and he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's just like let's do this like
he's like let's party let's get [ __ ]
up let's do whatever and then my mom's
like this like super super by the book
um you know
traditional conservative woman who is
basically
like a robot she like shut down all her
craziest parts and she's just the
simplest fewest moving Parts yeah I mean
she has wires in her body instead of
blood let me put it that way you know
what I mean
that's impressive yeah so she it's
what's weird she's a kind of a freak of
nature she's also like a [ __ ] genius
and I think that causes her issues with
socialization and communication yeah she
means like because she's so so much
smarter than people it's like I'm not
like these people I mean not even engage
in this emotional animalistic [ __ ]
there exactly and like like she's the
smartest person in my entire family and
there's a lot of people in my family
that are Engineers like on my mom's side
they're all really [ __ ] smart and uh
so like she's just I don't know she's
just smarter than [ __ ] anybody I've
ever met and
my dad is like more like me like I'm
pretty similar to my dad but uh it's
just weird because I think that's maybe
that's why I have problems communicating
with women because I'm used to
communicating with a person who's my
mom's like she manages people at a
market research company and she's very
like analytical and by the book so I
have communication patterns in common
with her but my personality is like my
dad so basically what I'm saying is I
was essentially just born to be a
[ __ ] comedy producer you know what I
mean dude you're just two different ends
of the spectrum you're a weird mix yeah
things but yeah I mean uh women you know
I feel like it's a case-by-case basis
and it's like a day by day basis like
with women yeah like I'm like sometimes
I'm like good at you know communicating
and getting along with a woman and then
sometimes it's like I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on
do you think that's on you or on them
though both Maybe
I think like culturally there's a lot of
strife between men and women and I know
like you're like pretty uh prolific with
the women so you might not experience a
lot of it but maybe you do maybe
experience more of it because you're
just out there more
but it's like I I just think that
there's like a bad there's like a bad uh
Vibe I feel like it's not really working
out right now I think you're right dude
I
I mean yeah I guess uh I kind of
womanized a little bit but I
I mean dude I know I don't know I guess
people wouldn't expect me to say this
but I would like to like find a woman to
settle down with and get married one day
and have more kids and have like a nice
family that's that's really what I would
prefer like when I can't find a [ __ ]
woman that's like stable enough dude it
drives me nuts honestly well would they
say the same thing about you that you're
not stable
yeah probably I guess I should fix my
own life before I go trying to find a
woman to have a family with you're
probably right on the money there but I
mean sometimes you need a woman to help
fix you like how much do you have to fix
yourself whereas you could find a woman
to Speedline
Speedline speed up the process Main Line
some change man
um
yeah that's a interesting take well I
think I've done that before where I've
tried to like
I've put out like a vibe that women take
as oh I gotta fix this guy and then and
then I don't think that's healthy
however I think it probably is
beneficial to me for to find a woman
like that that's kind of how my me and
my ex were like we were like
simultaneously were like trying to help
fix each other and she's in a lot I
don't know I think it actually it
honestly it was probably really
beneficial to both of us because she was
you know
stripping and now she's a realtor
so she's in a better place I'm stripping
uh in open houses to sell them for
stripping houses
um
next up to the stage at Rambler
she's just for Keller Williams
objectifying we have Jade
now I I uh I yeah I mean yeah why not
it's good to have a uh you could have
like a codependent relationship if
you're mutually beneficial and helping
each other grow yeah maybe that's what
it is I don't know I'm dude I'm
definitely not the guy to ask about
relationships I've never had a good one
like ever
I mean you had good times in
relationships I'm sure well I've had
good times with a lot of [ __ ]
one-night stands and [ __ ] and
strippers too you know like that's great
yeah string those along it's not as it's
not as um
what's the word here Rich it's not as
um like it it feels better to be in a
relationship with someone who you grow
with over time that's a more fulfilling
that's the word I was looking for yeah
filling experience yeah the gains are
exponential right 100 on top yeah yeah
until until you uh
you know [ __ ] destroy it well I think
the economic thing is the worst because
like girls have a hard time they get
paid less you know they they're uh
career opportunities are limited so they
kind of have to [ __ ] the right person to
have any decent standard of living yeah
yeah and then uh guys are just like
I don't know where our self-worth is
based on the attractiveness of the girls
that are willing to [ __ ] us
yeah well that's interesting that you
say that because that means in the
universe of that is that a woman's uh
mating
value and and her their attractiveness
is based on how many men want to [ __ ]
them divided by how many men actually
they they [ __ ]
right you know what I mean the fewer men
you [ __ ] the higher the value exactly
but the fewer the men you [ __ ] and the
more men that want to [ __ ] you which
means you're more exclusive and it's
it's like a [ __ ] Diamond you know
it's like an exclusive mineral but look
I don't want to sit here and compare
women to shiny rocks they're more like
dogs you know what I mean yeah they're
they need to be told what to do and just
hit them on the nose with the newspaper
and walked on a leash and it's fingered
yeah
I I think like relationships are great
continue
I think relationships are great I think
it's like uh
sometimes I want to interact with
Society with my penis and
I want to stick my dick in society
[Music]
for sure
and then sometimes you get
a sexually transmitted disease
oh yeah those are the worst yeah I call
them sexy infections
sex factions sex factions yeah let's go
with that that's cool
um yeah STDs are bad I think it's uh
even worse if we have like a repressive
culture where we don't talk about sex
and I think it's weird that there's like
diseases that are like oh if we just
hang around the dick
we can get into a vagina like it's crazy
that there's like diseases that are just
camped out on your groin yeah that's
it's it is really weird that they're
yeah that's a good that's a good point
because like most diseases affect your
entire body yeah in some capacity right
or maybe they have a specialty like the
lungs yeah uh yeah but so something
about like how many less people do you
think would smoke if if a side effect of
smoking cigarettes was like herpes you
know
well I think like sex is such a crazy
thing that they're like oh there's a lot
of potential energy here that we can use
and like diseases are like wait a minute
we can uh use this uh thing where people
come together in this really close way
and we can use that and we can make it
burn when they pee yeah yeah I agree
these people are burning to free or
peeing too freely right now yeah we need
to we need to you know we're yearning
for a burning
you know turn it sure yeah
I think that just goes to show you how
powerful sex is is that even diseases
are like yeah let's get in on that dude
I I think that uh with
I okay so when I was younger I always
thought that
the most powerful thing in the world was
[ __ ] like I thought everything was run
by [ __ ] and I realized later
that if it was they'd be doing a lot
better but unfortunately they're
suffering a lot exactly yeah women don't
don't control anything
um I think that the world is run by a
desire for control not even necessarily
power or money or [ __ ] but just uh the
the idea of being able to control other
people because I think that the people
that run the world are all Psychopaths
who want to control people that's what I
think it boils down to I mean it's like
the lowest common denominator it's like
back in the MMA early days people were
just trying to knock each other out all
the time because if you weren't trying
to knock each other out all the time you
would get knocked out you'd be sparring
someone and then get knocked out can we
can I get another one of these
I have a crippling alcohol addiction on
it's fine you're handling it well you
think so yeah so are you uh
are you like excited about uh dating are
you like excited about I'm never I'm
literally never gonna have a girlfriend
again I've decided
that sounds like a rule that's made to
be broken absolutely you want to just
have a woman come in your life and just
[ __ ] all your [ __ ] up because it's just
so broken as long as she's five foot
three and has a a darker complexion but
that's cool that you have the ability
I'll let her touch my butthole what you
want like because a lot of people are
just like I'll take big small fat skinny
like they don't have a choice but you
have like you can get down to the inches
what do you mean why why am I yeah
whatever's clever because you said you
only date five three women why do I
that's just what I'm attracted Oh you
mean like I'm Suave enough to be able to
just pull whatever yeah you got a
compact face it's efficiently designed
there's no extra space holy [ __ ] I mean
your nose that was the most Asian
analysis of my face I've ever heard
yeah it's uh you look like a typical
white boy you know like if anyone wants
to date like a pyromaniac that grew up
like a little kid that used to torture
squirrels I never tortured animals I did
used to catch [ __ ] on fire I actually uh
when I was a teenager we burnt the side
of the house we almost burned a house
down on New Year's because we were
[ __ ] uh stoned and lighting bushes on
fire
which I realize now sounds totally
psychotic don't look at me like that
um
but uh yeah we almost burned inside this
house down so you're kind of close I
never [ __ ] with animals though I don't
they don't deserve yeah no yeah I'm not
saying you're a bad person I'm just
saying like you look like that guy a bad
person it's weird dude I um I was it
okay so
I was with Bobby and laser at Twin Peaks
the other day and the waitress comes up
black chick and she's pretty hot and
she's talking to us and she's like hey
blah blah getting our order and Laser
says hey which one of us would you take
to prom if you had to take us to prom
right now and she's not like younger
anything she was like 23. but it was
just like a funny joke it's so old what
what are you Leonardo DiCaprio Jesus
um but uh but she goes she's she's like
yeah uh I would take you laser you know
she didn't know his name but she said
she pointed the laser and then he said
he said who is who's second and then she
pointed to me and he goes really why and
she said because he looks like a a
[ __ ] white [ __ ] boy
yeah you have the I'm a family man of
society at your fingertips you go into a
convenience store you get to do whatever
the [ __ ] you want in there dude I
literally have been to jail more than
anybody I know I don't think I just get
to do whatever I want no you don't but
you look like you do
yeah you look like you can go you know
skiing in the in Breckenridge I've never
been skiing I grew up I grew up kind of
poor actually
hmm that's funny that you say that
because I look like a like a wealthy
white kid from a white family yeah you
look like the people that this Society
is designed for I look like that but I'm
not at all that's that's fine I know
most people aren't it's only designed
for a certain number of people but for
the last think about it as a race thing
to make ourselves feel better and that's
the only thing we can understand oh yeah
well I will say Society has probably
benefited me to a degree because I look
like that for sure because when I was a
kid like we used to like check cars and
[ __ ] like rob houses and [ __ ] and uh
these black kids we robbed this house
with they got arrested and um
I wasn't there for this so this is not a
totally Perfect Analogy but like I did
something very similar with one of my
other friends and there was like two
black kids two white kids and then in
this separate robbery it was me and this
other white dude and the two black dudes
did they they went to jail jail and then
two of the white dudes went to jail and
then me and the other this other dude
kind of got off so it was like
I didn't have as extensive as a criminal
record as they did so that probably
played a part in it but I also imagined
that me being a white kid from a
middle class suburb and they were from
section 8 housing probably played a role
in it but
um yeah I don't know I I just kind of a
side note side thought yeah I mean I'm
sure there were some advantages that you
got but you know like it's not like a
great
uh system that we have it doesn't treat
people very well it's better than a lot
of other places though that we probably
have destroyed through bones and bombed
yeah bombs mostly I think
I mean we don't do bombs anymore we have
drone straightways economic Hitmen and
we have ways of [ __ ] with countries
dude I I honestly think that we're at
the end of the Imperial we're at the end
of an Empire
this is post-imperial America I mean we
invaded Iraq and Afghanistan what the
[ __ ] is there yeah like oil maybe a
little bit more heroin too not even like
the leading World we're like running out
of countries to invade yeah dude I think
that we're [ __ ] and that China's gonna
take us over in our lifetime
I genuinely think that and I don't think
in like a way where they're gonna
Parachute from the sky like in Red Dawn
and [ __ ] shoot us it's going to be in
an economic way yeah live by the sword
Die By The Sword you ruled your your
like money is your God then money can
take you down yeah that's all it takes I
think that we have to wake up and try to
create a better society and I think like
this idea of just being ruled by greed
is uh it's not a good idea well that's
nothing you just said is gonna happen
were [ __ ]
but has there ever been a society that's
prevented its downfall once it started
no never it seems so easy like if
America was a person and they were just
like a greedy you know ah [ __ ] it
I'll take it like wouldn't you be like
oh this guy is gonna hit rock bottom and
then there's there's gonna be a you know
a come-up story yeah but it's not just
one person it's 350 million people and
also even if it was one person have you
ever like dealt with somebody who has
like one obvious Achilles heel that if
they stopped doing it they would be
better like a lot of strippers are like
that like strippers have these like
issues with like insecurities because
they were raped or something like that
and like they have to go to these clubs
to show their [ __ ] titties so that
they can feel empowered to make the
money and they're blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah and you can tell them 10
times over like hey going into this
strip club and showing your tits for
money is damaging your mental health and
it's causing you to have a drug problem
and et cetera et cetera and I'm not
talking about anybody in particular I'm
just saying like I've hung out in a lot
of strip clubs yeah like you tell those
that they don't [ __ ] want to listen
they don't care it takes forever it
takes years for them to get their [ __ ]
there's no way to have people get better
like David Goggins what about him okay
don't you think if David Goggins cannot
be fat we can stop destroying rain David
Goggins is a unique person America is
not a unique situation we're very I
in certain ways yeah the American
experiment is unique but also dude like
we're pretty similar to Rome and other
democracies and representative republics
that have [ __ ] crumbled yeah but I
mean I don't think it's inevitable I
think there was a lot of time when Rome
wasn't crumbling though we could maybe
try to
do some some of the good things that
they did
I mean I think that uh
someone has to get their [ __ ] together
right no 100 and the good thing about
people is they die every 80 years so
yeah the only thing or you can make it
happen sooner too
yeah you can kill off the people in your
Society that's true we could kill people
in our society yeah what do you think
about mass shootings
well that's what I said earlier man we
need to legalize prostitution dude all
these kids shooting up schools are [ __ ]
deprived basically that's what I've
gathered
do you think that there'd be more [ __ ]
if we lived in like a European style
Scandinavian style Society probably but
I also
don't think that everybody should be
having orgies either just for the record
that's not what they're doing and be on
record saying that
I don't think we should all be having
orgies
but I think that we should also legalize
prostitution
so you can pay for your orgy just not
all the time
exactly dude that's exactly what I'm
getting at
I think sex is powerful I think it
brings people together and I think
that's why every society in the world
has repressed sexuality because I I'm
sorry I totally I'm on the same page as
you I agree I was semi-joking about the
orgy thing but I do not think that like
I I legitimately think that uh if
prostitution was legalized
I do think that they would cut down mass
shootings you know who originally told
me that was Eli
helper yeah he told he was the one that
came up with a very strong sex drive
both of you
I've dude I've been friends with him for
like 10 years
and uh
well I don't want to get into all the
[ __ ] we used to do but yeah prostitution
would relieve a lot of stress
well he told he told me that and he was
saying it in a joke but I think he's
pretty
I think he's actually pretty correct
because
it would relieve stress for these kids
that have never been laid number one
number two if you if you like had sex
with a hooker every month for a year and
you had like maybe like a bad like
confidence in your sex drive or
something like that
I mean in your in your uh sexual body
like yeah like your skills if you kept
[ __ ] hookers for like a year you
would develop like better seriously and
I think it would help like a guy that's
been practicing Guitar Hero every day
yeah she goes to like a Guitar Hero
convention and the other thing is like
there's always going to be [ __ ] no
matter what in any society there always
is no matter what it's like why do you
think that every society Asian Society
Middle Eastern Society European Society
they're all very repressive about sex
because because women I think can be the
downfall of societies because they make
men weak spineless backboneless men do
crazy [ __ ] and make bad decisions when
has that been the case what Society has
been crumbled by women like
um
if you if you uh look at like like
what's like some of these like European
countries that are like super just like
[ __ ] weak and being pushed over
they're they're well Chris
is that one of the um
with what banking like they owe a lot of
money
I just don't think women are good
leaders because they act on emotion as
opposed to logic which is just a
biological function but I think we need
more I think we're too driven by male
energy and I think a lot of the issues
could be fixed by women
name one woman you've ever seen solve a
problem
um
maybe uh a girl from Queen's Gambit
um
you know that girl that's all Swedish
like the 16 year old that's like talking
about global warming
um did you just name a 16 year old yeah
you think we should listen to a 16 year
old
yeah we should listen to everyone we
should judge that 16 year old has
nowhere near the experience or wisdom in
life to be telling anybody what they
should be [ __ ] doing that's a good
idea how old are you 33. I'm 29. I don't
think we should even really be telling
people so the oldest people in the world
are the only people because at a certain
point there's a cut off like Joe Biden
the [ __ ] Casino was the perfect age
then 49. so those are the only people we
should listen to the only people we
should listen to are all people that are
49ers what about all the students that
had the protests that were like helpful
and you know like the founding fathers a
lot of them were in their early 20s it
takes young people to like really think
differently all right you're right I was
wrong
I can see in my entire point no actually
I I I've had like nine of these so I
think that maybe I'm just going a little
off the deep end I I do take that back
you're probably right people maybe we
are right to be making decisions
actually
I just don't think women as a you can't
just be like women can't make decisions
or whatever um but yeah a lot of that is
this is I'm hyperbolic right I don't
think women are good leaders I don't
think that means they can't make
decisions I'm just not good leaders I
think people that think they're good
leaders are bad leaders I don't I would
oh that's interesting
I was gonna say I don't agree with you
but then
I'm trying to rack my brain
I don't think he was a great leader
no because he was divisive yeah based on
that alone I don't think he was
necessarily like a horrible president I
would say he's probably came in middle
of the road but as a leader you're not
good you're right yeah he was um
consensus building but yeah I mean I
think like it's the idea of this leader
that we need to be ruled over by someone
is like the queen thing like we don't
need a queen yeah everyone should be
able to make their own decisions and as
long as you're not harming anyone I
think overall people will make a great
society because everyone wants to
contribute you don't need to force
people yeah but dude that's how do you
think Society got to where it is now at
one point that's what it was people did
just say hey we can all just get
together and get along and then it
turned into this like yeah there's like
a bunch of angry vicious aggressive
people that were like hey let's take
over everything yeah but that's not even
like a function of
like happenstance or the the
variables and factors in society some
people are just born with biological
[ __ ] right and problems and some
societies exaggerate that like Asian
societies don't exaggerate that as much
as Western societies and I think it's
great that Western societies were as
successful as they are but I think uh
it's unsustainable
what what do you think the greatest
Society in the world is right now
because I have I mean I have an opinion
probably like Buddhists or Native
Americans I think Japan is the greatest
Society in the world right and I'm an
Asian supremacist so maybe I'm biased
but that's what I I genuinely believe
that I think they are the greatest
Society on earth and the one thing that
everybody always says when I tell them
that is well what about their suicide
rate it's a self it's it's a
self-solving problem the weakest people
are eliminating themselves like they
they're Geniuses dude they have created
a perpetuating genius cycle of Genius
just Geniuses dude the whole thing is
genius I think Western powers are great
for you know uniting us and giving us
Locomotion and steam-powered engines
yeah Locomotion I love it we can't just
use them forever like it's not
sustainable like we can't just like
follow white people forever like we need
to like tap into like Buddhism or yeah
American [ __ ] I want
to be
owned by a Japanese family
they just set you loose like here going
to go crazy in this direction like oh
it's very crazy over there
dude I mean I respect the [ __ ] out of
Asian people because they're so [ __ ]
like I remember one time there was like
a [ __ ] you remember that uh that
nuclear power plant in sushima and they
cleaned it up so [ __ ] fast it was
insane dude and I remember no they
that's how it happened it was like way
quicker than [ __ ] we what we would do
yeah and I was just like holy [ __ ] that
was our government that's a cohesive
Society you're right it was the
government so that's what that's an
example when a government does
government is a tool like it can be used
good or bad and it's 100 speaking for
the voice of the people then it's like
oh we can get everyone everyone come
here and throw buckets of nuclear waste
in the ocean then it's better than it's
like oh we got to pay people and like um
yeah I don't know it's like if you can
just be like hey Community Driven almost
yes and people want to help so it's not
that's because they have a culture that
that pushes that we have a culture
that's like hey it's me me first me mine
I me me me which is great I just don't
think that it's like I don't think it is
I think that's why we have great movies
we have great stand-ups great musicians
even all that shit's been going downhill
for a long time I think like the one
thing we that America does have in
Spades is the comedy here is the
greatest on Earth easily yeah I mean
it's people that are sucking our own
dicks here but we are the best yeah
we're free we don't have to think about
our culture and be like
oh I want to make this joke but the
queen would be offended but dude that's
how it is in like LA and [ __ ] where
people are self-censoring because
they're afraid the crowd's gonna feel a
certain way
that's why Austin's the [ __ ] dude
yeah I mean the crowd is always gonna
have their opinion on things yeah
yeah they will but in Austin it's you
don't have like woke PC crowds like
booing people if they say something yeah
but you don't also don't want to be like
uh Jeff Dunham or like lowest common
denominator comedy right right right
right well dude like example when when
what the [ __ ] is that
trap house
oh that's me
that was your phone yeah
for some reason it started playing
um what I was gonna say though is like
the uh the Austin comedy scene is pretty
[ __ ] awesome because
uh there's obviously been a large
demographic of people here that want the
you know non-pc Raw
excuse me comedy for a long time
and when Rogan and Hinchcliffe and kill
Tony and a lot of people came out here
they finally got that and they enjoyed
it like when that thing happened with
pong dang and Tony said [ __ ] it didn't
like the crowd was laughing and
obviously it was contextualized because
we were there but like
nobody in the [ __ ] room was upset
about that yeah no no you're gonna start
lynching Asian people that's not a real
concern yeah that was dude that that
[ __ ] was really really really plotted
out I think I think pong dang knew that
it was Asian appreciation month or
whatever and he was like yo I'm gonna
have my homeboy record this and then
we'll speed it up through the parts that
were funny we'll just see have Tony
saying [ __ ] a bunch of times blah blah
blah and just make him look bad and use
that as [ __ ] clout to get ahead and
basically
eat one of his own like he [ __ ] over
somebody that gave him a [ __ ]
platform that guy's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
and to be like oh he's racist like dude
you're a parasite yeah that's even worse
100 system 100 [ __ ] percent that I
mean whatever dude that [ __ ] was so
bizarre that was a surreal situation
overall yeah it benefited you though for
[ __ ] sure yeah Tony didn't give a
[ __ ] about me until that happened yeah
but yeah I mean
that that's not true though yeah I had a
couple good sets on kill Tony I I don't
I don't think he didn't get not give a
[ __ ] about you I think he just was like
this guy's funny this is a whole crazy
situation let's let's throw this guy an
opportunity you know what I mean yeah
it's I mean it's hard to pay attention
to everyone he has so many people in his
in his uh orbit trying to get his
attention
but yeah I mean uh
yeah it was it was bad energy it was
like
oh we're not all comedians some of us
are our pieces of [ __ ] yeah that's so
weird too especially in comedy well
what's your take on like how uh
comedians you know every every comic
I've ever met is like hey we can all eat
at the same table and we can all eat and
blah blah blah but like most of them I
don't think even abide by that I think
most people are pretty Cutthroat and
selfish in comedy I mean am I wrong you
know it's hard it's hard to be in a room
with someone where you're like oh that
guy's funnier than me or oh that guy's
not as funny as me either way like you
got to think that they're exactly as
funny as you to treat them decently so
it's a difficult thing the best way for
me to think about it is like he's funny
like Joe said this he's funny but I'm
also funny in my own way like I'm not
gonna be funny copying him and it's not
like a sport where like there's someone
who can jump the highest we all need our
different diverse voices to chime in
it's not like a competition it's like oh
uh we all need to be the best version of
ourselves so it's it's it's it should be
more like that than like a sport which
sports can be great too
but yeah I think it should be more like
a more uh womanly or more hippie way to
look at it instead of like a male or
like a capitalistic way of like there
can only be one winner yeah I agree that
that the capitalistic way of looking at
it is it is uh not not the best for when
it comes to Comedy
um I I mean dude I don't know man I
foreign
I think men are funnier than women
because it's it's an evolutionary trait
women don't need to be funny to get laid
men do if you're not good looking or
Rich you need to or have some sort of
status in society you need to be funny
to [ __ ] well maybe that's just our
certain like this the way that it is now
because we're in like giant
megalopolises or like giant cities and
you got to make a good first impression
but maybe back in the day you could just
be like a really quiet good Bow Hunter
and women would love that back in the
day you say it like you were there
[ __ ] 3000 years ago yeah back in the
days yeah if you're a good bow hunter
you get that humor you get the hottest
[ __ ] in the town man you could just be
really good at basket weaving
um but yeah I don't I don't know like
humor I think is is uh I think it's a
way of thinking that is positive and I
think women are thinkers too
and that they can think in a positive
way and oh yeah don't get me wrong
there's plenty of funny women I just
it's the ratio is way different and it's
not it's not because it's like a
misogynistic industry at least in my
experience it's just it really is
because men well I think like humor and
comedy there's like a lot of raw
emotions that maybe are unpleasant that
men are able to like you know like plow
through that women are probably like
gonna be like oh this is like kind of
bad vibes
and maybe they're they're going to be
attracted to other Industries
um like like
uh being an esthetician or a gymnast
yeah
yeah no I agree or cheerleading yeah I
don't think that a lot of women want to
do stand-up comedy I think it's kind of
a brutal art form especially since
you're 100 [ __ ] percent men are a
little more self-destructive and they
don't care about themselves as Risk
Takers yeah because our our bodies are
useless are like not useless but our
bodies are sacrificed to society Jesus
Christ dude like our we can be replaced
by one man coming it's like an eight
million sperm but like women have like
you know one baby at a time or maybe if
they have you know two twins or triplets
or Octomom type situation
yeah it can never count out an Octomom
situation but I think uh yeah humor is
important I really gotta pee do you want
to call how long have we been recording
I'm gonna probably pee my pants let's
call it
all right see you guys later